The Dog and The Bone.
Once a stray dog passing by a butcher shop found a nice, juicy piece of bone.
The dog was very pleased.
He clutched the bone hard with his teeth and ran towards the woods to eat it.
He then had to walk across the bridge over a stream...
...through the gaps in the wooden bridge.
The dog could see his own reflection.
But the foolish dog thought it was another dog staring at him...
...with a nice juicy bone in his mouth.
He decided that he had to have the other dog's bone as well.
The greedy fellow barked.
As soon as he did this, the bone fell into the water.
The poor dog was terribly upset at losing his bone...
...but he said to himself, "Let that be a lesson to me."
"Never to be so greedy again."